[Music]  most people think mitt romney won the  debate last night this is even more  impressive given one of romney's  physical takes look what we've done  thank you jim it's an honor to be here  with you and i appreciate the chance to  be with the president i'm pleased to be  at the university of denver i appreciate  their welcome the other thing we have to  do to save medicare  we have to have the benefits high for  those that are low income i met a couple  in appleton wisconsin and they said  we're thinking of dropping our insurance  we can't afford it  wrote and said  what we did in massachusetts could be a  model for the nation  and i agree that  the democratic legislators in  massachusetts might have given some  advice i will keep america strong and  get america's middle class working again  thank you jim  [Music]